R&B singer art Kelly will appear in
federal court in Brooklyn next month to
fakes new sex crime charges federal
prosecutors in Illinois and New York
charging musician with a combined 18
counts including child pornography
Kelley is accused of sexually exploiting
women and girls over more than two
decades now he has denied all
allegations in an exclusive interview
with us back in March Kelley maintained
his innocent of any wrongdoing have you
ever had sex with anyone under the age
of 7 no never no Kelley is being held in
a Chicago jail without bond as crisis
manager Darrell Johnson is with us only
on CBS this morning Darrell it's good to
see you again
good morning listen I knew when I asked
that question I wasn't expecting him say
yes Gale as a matter of fact I have but
now he was arrested 10 days ago while he
was walking his dog he's now facing 195
years in prison based on the Chicago
charges alone you're feeling his feeling
this time around is what well mr. Kelly
is a mess right now so well he's he's
afraid he's scared he's like he's
isolated well let's focus on the
allegations first and then we'll get
back to his mental state your feeling
about these latest charges does he
believe that he'll be acquitted again
does this case feel different to you
this time it does feel different but I
said from the beginning that if you have
the book the book has to keep 20 tapes
if you read the indictment it's only
five tapes it's not 20 tapes I don't
think the number of the tapes is issue
Darrell I think what's on the tapes is
the issue and now comes word that the
one of the victims in 2008 is now
cooperating with authorities doesn't
this make this case different this time
I don't see how if she said that nothing
happened it wasn't her her mother said
it wasn't her father said it wasn't her
she's cooperating this time though she's
no different story allegedly well he was
acquitted in this case with the same
young lady Kelly has repeatedly said
that he doesn't have any money right now
he can't make any because he can't go
perform how is he paying for his
legal-defense or other celebrities other
musicians providing him money well mr.
Kelly does have royalties they come in
so he's living on some of these roads
that he had
and early on fans and friends made a lot
of donations how do you explain all of
these allegations I know mr. Kelly and
yourself and all of his team have said
he's absolutely innocent you have so
many women who have come forward and
they're telling the same story for a
long period of years or all of these
women just not telling the truth here's
why I say I've never called anybody a
lawyer I came on seven months ago I
walked into a front door and I see mr.
Kelly been a normal person I've seen as
real in Jocelyn those are the two women
who are women now they won I came in
unsuspected no wonder what time I was
coming I arrived mr. Kelly was recording
20 minutes later Ezreal and Jocelyn
walked in with shopping bags no security
three doing what they wanted to do and I
spent a lot of time with Kelly and I
still say my eye is trained I haven't
seen anything that would cause me to be
suspicious of Daryl Daryl of course you
wouldn't see me I came in and saw mr.
Kelly being a normal person too
but sitting at his kitchen counter
drinking tea all of that I saw that too
we are not going to see that type of
behavior the question is all of these
women through through decades now have
been telling the same story right you
and I aren't going to see that or
someone if we walked in his house what
do you say to all of these women what I
say the question that haunts many people
absolutely I understand that what I'd
say is again they've been dating mr.
Kelly he's in jail right now he would
have his day in court
and they would have to bring the
evidence and that's what has to be done
if the evidence stick miss Keller would
spend the rest his life in the
penitentiary
you have a twenty-something year old
daughter would you allow her to be alone
definitely not with our Kelly I wouldn't
leave my daughter with anybody that's
accused of pedophilia so you hear you so
you were not I would not leave my
daughter when anyone that's accused of
being a pedophile I would not that
doesn't seem like a contradiction to you
you're absolutely depending our Kelly
but at the same time saying you wouldn't
leave your own daughter with it I
wouldn't leave our daughter anyone come
on say it again that's accused of being
a pedophile all right
you started the beginning talking about
mr. Kelly's mental health
what is his mental health is he under
suicide watch are you concerned
absolutely I am concerned about mr.
Kelly is he under suicide watch
I would assume at this point he is mrs.
Kelly is a mess I mean you know I've
heard great statements that he's happy
and this is going on and he wanted to be
at this particular place it's absolutely
not true no one wants to be locked down
24 hours no TV he can't read and write
so he can't read a book it's almost as
if he's already been a jury's convicted
him are you concerned about him harming
himself while he's in Pelham I am
absolutely harming himself how I don't
know and when you in the state of mind
miss Kelly in right now any person
including myself or you would probably
want to the thought to be cautious of
what is taking place thank you Darrell
Johnson you're walking in today thank
you